what do you think is the mind of
Einstein's God do you think there's a
way that we could untangle from this
from this universe of strings why are we
here what is the meaning of it all
well Steven Weinberg winner of the Nobel
Prize once said that the more we learn
about the universe the more we learned
that is pointless
well I don't know I don't profess to
understand the great secrets of the
universe however let me say two things
about what the Giants of physics have
said about this question
Einstein believed in two types of God
one was the God of the Bible the
personal God the God that answers
prayers walks on water as performs
miracles smites the Philistines that's
the personal God that he didn't believe
in he believed in the God of Spinoza the
God of order simplicity harmony Beauty
the universe could have been ugly the
universe could have been messy random
but it's gorgeous you realize that on a
single sheet of paper we can write down
all the known laws of the universe it's
amazing on one sheet of paper
Einstein's equation is one inch long
string theory is a lot longer and so
it's a standard model but you could put
all these equations on one sheet of
paper it didn't have to be that way it
could have been messy and someone Stein
thought of himself as a young boy
entering this huge library for the first
time being overwhelmed by the simplicity
elegance and beauty of this library but
all he could do was read the first page
of the first volume well that library is
the universe with all sorts of
mysterious magical things that we have
yet to find and then Galileo was asked
about this Galileo said that the purpose
of science the purpose of science is to
determine how the heavens ago the
purpose of religion is to determine
how to go to heaven so in other words
science is about natural law and
religion is about ethics how to be a
good person how to go to heaven as long
as we keep these two things apart we're
in great shape the problem occurs when
people from the Natural Sciences begin
to pontificate about ethics and people
from religion begin to pontificate about
natural law that's where we get into big
trouble you think they're fundamentally
distinct morality and ethics and our our
idea of what is right and what is wrong
that's something that's outside the
reach of string theory in physics that's
right if you talk to a squirrel about
what is right and what is wrong yes
there there's no reference frame for a
squirrel and realize that aliens from
out of space if they ever come visit us
they'll try to talk to us like we talked
to squirrels in the forest but
eventually we get bored talking to the
squirrels because they don't talk back
to us
same thing with aliens from out of space
and they come down to earth
they'll be curious about us to a degree
but after a while they just get bored
because we have nothing to offer them so
our sense of right and wrong what does
that mean compared to a squirrels sense
of right and wrong now we of course do
have an ethics that keeps civilizations
in line enriches our life and makes
civilization possible and I think that's
a good thing but it's not mandated by a
law of physics
you